Ashikaga  is recovering at a hospital in Mumbai  after undergoing a seven-hour operation  the teenager's father said his son put  up with tooth and jaw pain for over a  year  it hurt for him to eat  he was only chewing on one side of his  mouth and when food touched the other  side it caused a burning sensation  doctors in the boys village were unable  to help and they referred him to  specialists they recognized the  condition as Oden Toma in which a tumors  beneath the gums produces tooth like  growths called denticles in total  surgeons extracted 232 teeth we could  imagine that it's a it's going to be a  world record while during surgery we  were unaware that we will encounter so  many so many people so many denticles  in a little over a week aashiq will get  his stitches removed and then he will be  able to show off his new smile